yooz monde c'est squeeze et comme vous
avez pu voir sur twitter je suis rentré
de vacances mais j'ai pas encore fait de
vidéo
simplement parce que je sors pas mal ces
temps-ci puis surtout que je travaille
sur une grosse vidéo plutôt que de faire
des vidéos sur sneijder ou quoi mais ça
va revenir on ne s'inquiétait pas je
préfère échanger faire une vidéo plutôt
spécial qui arrivera dans bas dans les
jours qui suivent le plot de cette vidéo
accueil très convaincante c'est un peu
contre l'espagne pistache risque
actuellement et du coup en attendant je
me suis dit que j'allais quand même vous
proposer une petite vidéo donc c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui cette vidéo et
upload
oui monsieur donc pour ceux qui ça fera
j'ai fait une petite polo de trois
semaines donc en corse j'ai pu emprunter
un jour l'appareil photo d'une des
personnes de la colo donc j'ai pris
quelques vidéos quelques scènes aient
eux aussi en ont pris pour moi donc avec
ces quelques scènes j'ai réussi à faire
un truc potable on va dire de vacances
bon ça dure qu'une mes nuits mais bon
voilà c'est déjà ça puis j'espère que ça
vous plaira donc je lance à tout de
suite à tout à l'heure
à
doublement en pleurant la soul r'n'b
jaune et l'a tellement je t'aime je
t'aime tu vas faire là dans ce qu'on
fait c'est qui
quelles sont vos impressions des armes
mène et jean-pierre avez vous mal oui
c'était vraiment douloureux
ces deux mois
donc voilà j'espère que ça vous aura plu
est en tout cas j'ai passé une petite
heure et demie à faire ce petit montage
bon voila j'ai façon j'adore faire ce
genre de montage
et puis bah au moins ça vous ça vous
monte quelque chose de mes vacances vrai
dire et puis maintenant à une petite
surprise je t'aime
générique de fin tu as envie de dire ça
je vais
non